hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the plight now I didn't
get a lot of backstory on this game but
it's an indie horror game from game Joel
which means that you can expect some
jump scares I don't know when I don't
know how high what ah I didn't know how
right I would be hello why is that child
murdering his family why is grandma so
scary grandma what have you done Oh No
oh hello hi how's it going I had a
feeling I had a feeling I had a funny
good hello why am i home now okay ah
what a lovely house I have what a lovely
place I live in Oh joyous day Oh
frabjous day Callooh Callay
hello who else is in here
Oh inventory okay well that's easy
enough a little shrine here a little
newspaper clipping oh boy three local
missing children found dead over three
years great this is wonderful so happy
about this was this okay I'm sure this
is gonna come in handy for seeing the
jump scares popping out in front of me
of which there's probably gonna be many
okay hello hi whoa what a dirty bathroom
Oh does this have something to do with
the grudge uh cuz that the child was all
cashed in gray which usually means
something grudge like it's gonna happen
no I've
fortunately locked every door in my
house in the aim of preventing wow this
is sparse it seems like a dorm room more
than a bedroom hello drawing block oh
we're gonna have story time well mommy
and daddy had a child that they love
very very much but one day everyone died
the end oh god oh hi grandma
well grandma don't look so good maybe
you should get some lights in the house
grandma Oh
boy and then you got a new family a
slightly less colorful family and then
grandma killed everybody oh my god oh
geez
well that page is torn out um okay we're
gonna be oh I thought there was gonna be
something by me I'm gonna let my guard
down for one second what is that okay
hello right
oh hey okay
I did oh um I'm bowing oh okay
ah and orange okay who's that
what happened who did that
that's not good this flashlight does
dick oh this flashlight does take well
jeez what was that hi
okay I probably should go take care of
that huh yeah yeah this flashlight does
nothing it's a piece of [ __ ] oh boy
hello hi who's over there I don't know
who's over there hi hello hello somebody
home hmm I don't know what to do what is
that oh okay is this a clue oh sorry
okay
oh yeah grandma oh boy
so something on the behind no okay now
what oh yay oh boy grandma grandma uh
poisoned someone okay now what how what
do I do now what do we do guide me oh hi
what how long were you there hello what
are you are you okay oh you don't look
okay
whoa how long were you there for and why
oh oh I got a click and hold oh he's
gone
oh I'm God hi hi grandma are you doing
ready ooh
eat your porridge I'm guessing or rice
probably hello grandma
I didn't do anything what did you do I
didn't do anything oh hi grandma
what are you doing why are we going
through memory lane oh boy
hello oh good hi hi what is happening
okay that's weird
that's weird oh here we go
ah good everyone's being happy grandma's
playing with the girl from the ring in a
lovely game of volleyball there anybody
on the ground that I should know about
oh geez oh geez
well the music's starting to pick up
which is either good or bad but I'm
gonna go with bad oh hello
ah poison plush oh my favorite plushy
toy I'm gonna keep it by my bed every
night and now I'm gonna worry about my
own death mmm-hmm oh yeah here we go
okay hello oh oh the game of volleyball
didn't go so well
grandma was mad about a cheater uh okay
everything's fine so far
I guess walk off with you
catching me on my intake breath it hurts
okay I think it's fine
ah damn it it's not fine was it
something new in here Oh too late too
late for what tea huh too late too late
too late too late okay
two second let me get a good okay okay
oh okay
uh uh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no okay oh hi oh man
oh man
uh oh good oh no oh oh god oh oh okay
let me get a good look at that
Oh who's there plush I can have a
hanging plush Oh God
oh so horrible oh there it is okay
I got the Hanged plush grain I'm gonna
have the whole collection gotta collect
them all and by all I mean all of the
nightmares gotta collect all of those
see this game is interesting because
it's less about like the straight-up
scares it's more about building this
atmosphere of just creepiness like the
feeling that something is going horribly
horribly wrong is something that uh is
is um it is something that I respect in
games that are made because it makes it
makes you think
it makes you think that there are things
worse out there than they really are
and then it meets the expectations
laters is how it should be done but I
can't seem to find the next clue
closed myself in the bathroom and forget
about all my troubles remember the good
old days when I was talking to a blood
baby in the bathtub
or the sink everything was fine then oh
hello
hi oh I got a key which door is this go
to I found the door oh don't do that
elderly Chinese woman found mutilated on
home with catatonic child maybe it
wasn't the grandma maybe was the kid
that possessed grandma
woogie learn another key
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no okay is this going upstairs
hello oh oh well I thought I was looking
at a pair of legs to a giant creature
who's just rolled up rugs oh oh boy okay
so it is it is the child child's doing
all the work
that's the bathtub downstairs hello hi
hello flaming doll I guess I guess I'll
come back for you in a second
do I not need you right now why there's
so many rugs was it all right oh boy oh
boy oh boy
ah that's that's that's drowning that's
drowning right there oh good thing we
got such an artiste but I saw something
oh sorry I'm getting freaked out oh boy
oh boy just nothing in here oh I gotta
fill up the time there's delay oh boy oh
oh don't stick your face in the water hi
hello Oh
Oh God hello oh no oh oh oh yeah whole
house flooded can't see damn thing woof
woof am I supposed to go around and
explore why no I can't leave this area
hi hello yeah don't go dunk in your head
and death water it's no good
got the drowned plush though this next
up is the elderly woman yeah who's found
two dismembered in her bed so what about
what about this guy
okay okay okay oh oh okay oh wow to be
continued
what my murder the seagulls is gonna be
me being brutally murdered in a bathtub
and then being hanged and then being
killed a million times over but that was
good that was well done I mean the
animations were a bit janky but for a
small team in an indie horror game that
was well done they did the atmosphere
and that's what I appreciate more than a
lot of jump scares in a game they got
the atmosphere I was feeling it like I
was literally feeling it that was good
I enjoyed that and I'm like that's why I
like these indie horror games because
they're small bite-sized pieces of
what's good about horror and you know
you'll come across like the cliche jump
scare that'll be fun and then you'll
come across a game like this that is
just kind of horribly terrifying you
don't want to take two steps cuz it's so
freaking dark and I know why they made
the flashlight so dark because if it
would have been brighter I would have
been able to see more but the sense of
like not having
knowledge of what's in front of my face
kind of led me to believe that there was
going to be like monsters constantly
popping out from the darkness but that
was good my hair is weird today I
apologize for my weird hair but I just
popped out of the shower but thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
play this game and support the
developers down to the link in the
description below and thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
yes